Butterflies soar using big wings and slow
flaps—about 20 times slower than the beat
of a honeybee.
To see how they fly with such odd timing and
equipment, scientists used high-speed video
to capture the body posture and motion of
butterflies flying in the lab.
Then, they simulated how each wingbeat pushes
air around—and how that changes with different
flying techniques.
It turns out, butterflies rotate their bodies
with each wingbeat—that waggle helps them
move upwards.
Toning down the waggle and tilting forwards
pushes them ahead.
In this way, butterflies can get where they
need to go, in their own jerky, erratic way.